sponsored by step finance your go to
d5 portfolio manager once bitmex the
og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to another episode
of the leia higher pen show so this podcast as
you know by now is sponsored by the og crypto
derivative exchange bitmex so some really great
news for them they've actually recently launched
a spot exchange which basically means you can now
easily buy and sell bitcoin and many other crypto
currencies on that platform it's actually a brand
new interface super slick super easy it's an
amazing place to buy and sell your crypto so
definitely recommend them also i want to make
sure that we do say thank you to them because
on this show we do talk about a lot of supposedly
controversial things like freedom authoritarianism
um some things which people would call conspiracy
theories which are proving to be true um so
without bitmex we wouldn't be able to provide you
such important conversations so huge thank you to
bit mex um and if you are interested in signing up
and you know buying your crypto through them and
buying a bitcoin through them then i'm actually
gonna leave a link for you in the description
um and all the information is there so a huge
thank you and a massive shout out to bitmex
so let's kick this off today we're having
a little bit of a different conversation
so i'm very excited to get it going joining me
today is nick battia the author of layered money
nick welcome to the show thank you thank you
so much for having me yeah it's my pleasure
um for those that don't know i've read the book
i reread it this weekend um i really enjoyed it
um it has an amazing background of the history of
money and sort of how we got to where we are today
um so massive um i said thank you for coming on
for those that don't know who you are can you
give us just a brief background about you sure
absolutely i come from the traditional finance
world i used to be uh in the investment management
industry i was a bond trader i traded treasuries
and other interest rate products and then
moved on to the strategy and research side of
fixed income uh before falling down the bitcoin
rabbit hole and starting to write about topics
like lightning lightning network bitcoin derived
interest rates and bitcoin as a reserve currency
so in about 2019 i decided to leave behind my
traditional career and go full time as a bitcoin
writer and i wrote layered money during the
pandemic 2020 and published it in january of 2021.
why did you decide to leave
what happened at that point
well basically over the course of 2016 to 2018 as
i was learning about bitcoin and started to write
about bitcoin i could see the writing on the
wall that the traditional industry as it stood
at that time was not going to last it wasn't going
to last forever and as a young person i want to
go to where the world is going not where it
is today and i just saw that bitcoin would be
absolutely at the center of world finance going
forward for the next few decades and that's
really why i decided to just learn as much as i
could about bitcoin then at a certain point um
i had written several articles about lightning
network and bitcoin that had achieved some
popularity in the bitcoin community and
basically i got some encouragement from
people to continue writing about bitcoin
and so i just took the leap of faith and
left my career behind and started the
teaching and writing phase of my career
i think that's such a big leap i mean it's not
a big leap when you are so convinced right but
it is a big leap in terms of leaving something
that you that you just know very well and it's
something that you're comfortable with um so you
said that you just knew the traditional system
sort of had an expiry date basically um
what's not gonna last about it so the
way that money is created today in the fractional
reserve way i believe it's unsustainable because
the dollar itself has lost its form so back
in the day we're talking about 100 years ago
when the dollar was still convertible to gold
it had some backing right it had a sense of
an anchor but today 50 years removed from the
gold standard and also 15 years removed from
the onshore dollar system being the only thing
that the federal reserve backs and i'm referring
to in 2007 when the fed issued a central bank
swap line to the european central bank and the
swiss national bank that basically made the euro
and the swiss franc as derivatives of the dollar
in a monetary hierarchy sort of way so we have
really long lost any reality of the dollar it is
it is pervasive and it is across the
world in terms of what people use
their denomination and then all other all of these
other currencies are derivatives of the dollar
so everything is denominated in this system
but it's so unstable that i just don't
see it lasting in its current form
the way that it is i see that bitcoin being an
impetus for change we see that the central banks
are now announcing their central bank digital
currencies so their system in the future will be
derived off of this new central bank digital
currency uh mechanism and the current mechanism
really will be dying out you mentioned um
fractional reserve banking and i want to make that
really clear for people who don't know exactly
what that is so can you explain it to us and also
number one why is it bad and then once you
explain that explain why isn't it illegal sure
so fractional reserve banking is this idea that
the money that you have in your checking account
on deposit is issued to you by a private bank
not by the government and not by the central
bank and so how does the bank issue issue
that money to you they lend it into existence
and that lending process is done based off of
only a fraction of the total amount of money that
they lend held in reserve either in the form of
government bonds or reserves held at the central
bank so in that way the amount of base money in
the system is multiplied because only a fraction
of it needs to be held in reserve for a bank to
issue money so we have and why is it why is it bad
because then we have more money in circulation
than is actually reserved or that actually exists
at the base layer and that can cause runs on
the bank and financial crises unfortunately the
fractional reserve system is more or less inherent
in human tendency so why isn't it illegal because
people human beings accept fractional reserve
issued money as real money and they only demand
the real money in crisis and the time
between that happening is long enough for
people to accept it really
it's so fascinating because that it shouldn't
be i i don't know even if it's people accept it
i feel like it's because people just don't
know and aren't aware um because if you're
if your money isn't you know backed by whatever
it's supposedly backed by like let's just say
one to one with gold or something like that
um then surely it just becomes worthless
i i agree with you that people don't know
that their money is fractionally reserved
today they don't inherently understand that uh
but there are times throughout history where
the distinction is made very clear
to people that a gold coin and that a
piece of paper saying i promise to pay a gold
coin are not the same thing and i think that
and as you know that's a lot of what layered
money is about where we look at the history
of money and at what point did people start
accepting a piece of paper in in lieu of a coin
and how did that change the way that we
do business as a society and i believe
that the benefits from this way of using a
layered money system outweigh the costs and
advanced our society and our economy forward now
i'm not making a judgment as to at what point
did it go too far but i do point out that over
the course of the 1930s to 2007 that the dollar
because of this layered money system and
its complexity basically the dollar lost its
sanity and its credibility it
doesn't mean the dollar died in 2007
it doesn't even mean the dollar is going to die in
2027 but what happened in 2007 is that the dollar
it it made the world understand that the
dollar isn't real anymore it can it might
stay alive for another 50 to 100 years but that
it's just not real anymore and then we have the
rise of bitcoin and so a lot of bitcoins rise
can be explained by the fact that the dollar
it doesn't have that reality and so people have
to express that view via something so real estate
prices increase across the world commodity prices
increase across the world including gold and then
we have the birth of bitcoin which explodes
in value from zero to uh half a trillion to
a trillion dollars so if you want to explain why
bitcoin exists you can attribute some of it or all
of it to this idea of the dollar losing an anchor
or a reality during the 2007-9 financial crisis
and honestly the subsequent actions of the federal
reserve and other central banks since that time
so i'm gonna delve into all of that um in a minute
um because i wanna really make clear you know what
is laid money and like how bitcoin comes into
it and really also just like what level bitcoin
falls under um but we'll get into all that i
want to actually just get your take um just
on current events um you know like quantitative
tightening um that's uh about to start so
in your opinion do you think it's too late given
inflation is already here astronomical levels
and once this really does kick in what does
this mean for the everyday person right now
sure so uh i would direct people viewers to my sub
stack publication called the bitcoin layer people
can find it at thebitcoinlayer.substack.com i
just published a couple hours ago a piece on
quantitative tightening and quantitative easing
and really trying to explain it for the average
person that isn't necessarily familiar with the
ins and outs of monetary policy so that's what my
publication is about it's about research analysis
and education about bitcoin and macro things like
this topic so what is qte what is quantitative
tightening well to answer that we have to answer
what is qe qe is quantitative easing what is qe qe
is a way for the fed to ease interest rate policy
when rates are already at zero so we know that the
fed brought rates down to zero in 2008 during the
financial crisis but things weren't going as
much as they wanted them to and they couldn't
they didn't want to uh lower rates into negative
territory so what did they do instead they bought
bonds in an effort to try to lower interest
rates in other parts of the economy uh by pro
you know by providing a source of an extra
source of demand for those bonds that
didn't work so then they bought more bonds and
actually the second time that they bought bonds
rates didn't go down they went up and why
that is really important to understand why did
rates go up during qe2 and qe3 and qe4 instead
of down when the fed was buying treasuries that
buying of treasuries should send yields lower
because when prices go up yields go down but it
didn't it sent yields higher and treasury prices
lower why because of a psyche a traitor psyche
and when the fed is printing money or doing qe
it raises confidence so you sell the risk free
asset and you buy risky stuff and sends
yields higher and so the fed in 2015
started raising rates when they were at zero and
then by 2017 they said we're going to start doing
qt lowering the size of the balance
sheet and um so qt is the opposite of qe
and qe is buying bonds so qt
is letting those bonds mature
and not replacing them and in that way qt destroys
money because qe is the creation of money so with
rates at eight percent i mean sorry inflation
at eight percent right now the fed is trying to
tighten monetary policy in two ways by sorry
take your time you're giving us good information
here we need it we need a smooth we need a
smooth voice for us the fed takes my breath
away sometimes and what they're doing so
the fed is raising rates so they're tightening
policy they're raising rates but they're also
starting on june 1st today letting treasuries
mature and that money now is coming out of
circulation the balance sheet is decreasing and so
the source of demand for those bonds is now gone
from the market now when they did this in 2017-18
instead of sending yields up it sent yields lower
because of the confidence thing
without the fed's liquidity
the fed creates this fear
and then investors purchase treasuries because
they're scared and so they buy the risk-free asset
and they sell the risky stuff so the fed's
intent with qe and qt versus what actually
happens empirically is very interesting
to observe it's not the same and right now
we can exp expect that the double
tightening higher rates and qt will um
basically slow inflation and growth and so it's
not too late we're gonna see inflation and growth
come down we're seeing it starting already and um
how long will the fed be willing to tighten and
that's the question on everyone's mind and that's
what i've been writing a lot about at you know my
publication i'm watching the two-year yield seeing
when that is coming down materially that might put
pressure on the fed i'm also also watching stops
of course but i'm really watching the fed's um
reverse repo facility which is this concept
of the excess reserves in the system right
now it's at two trillion dollars so the
fed will destroy money i promise you guys
the fed will be destroying money qt will be going
on because there's 2 trillion in excess reserves
when does it stop we don't know but for now
they're going to go for it the question on my
mind is why are we in such a mess with inflation
because we're taught that those that govern
are supposed to be competent um you know and just
good at their job the experts know what they're
doing um so so i often end up thinking that
it's destruction by design um i don't think that
they're that incompetent and what's your take the
inflation is due to many things and i think that
it's it's fair to attribute the inflation across a
bunch of mismanagement from government and central
banks it is fair to attribute the inflation
to supply chain disruptions due to shutdowns
and you know a lot of the response to the pandemic
okay a lot of the supply chain disruptions
cause prices to spike across the economy
commodities input prices transport prices
labor disruption all of that stuff is causing
supply-side driven inflation without a doubt
and it's actually probably the primary driver okay
now we also have four and a half trillion of qe
that was also done during this time which
creates excess reserves in the system it creates
confidence it creates excess borrowing spending
and that drives inflation too so qe also
contributes to that and they go hand in hand right
so um and and honestly the immediate response qe
in the height of the pandemic versus the
subsequent extended qe well into 2021
and it's actually obscene i'll be very honest
with you the immediate response was okay you
you know you have this shock you have to provide
but then several trillion more of kiwi to follow
was was really unnecessary the evidence is the 2
trillion in excess reserves parked back at the fed
it means they went two trillion too
far or at least one and a half trillion
too far so a ridiculous amount of qe that they
did okay um but attributing of inflation to
exactly the fed or to the governments that
make all the mistakes would be i think too
singular it's really attributed to all of these
things and it's attributed to in my opinion not
letting the free market adjust because if the
free market would adjust we would have deflation
be allowed where companies fail banks fail
defaults happen and then prices come down
which brings demand out of the woodwork ready
to support the economy again a natural cycle
that's what i believe while at the same
time acknowledging that governments
have to respond to voters so they bail out
people companies banks when it's when it's
when it fits their policy when they see that that
can get them reelected and i'm sympathetic to the
people the individuals that need help when
uh they get fired for example unemployment
insurance and those types of things government
provides you know fiscal stimulus to those people
and um you know if that contributes a little bit
to inflation at the margin it's of my opinion that
that's okay but you know we have to also draw
the line to where the free market response is
allowed to happen and in 2008 and nine when we
didn't let that happen to all the european and
american banks uh you set us a precedent and
then that precedent it's dangerous because then
you always have to bail out the banks you
can never let them fail because it will
tear down everything and that's the moral
hazard regime that we live in today which
absolutely drives some or most of the frustration
that drives bitcoin demand back again to
bitcoin here we are so moral hazard with bank
bailouts is once again like a big part of the
fundamental demand for bitcoin at least you know
in the first several years of his of its existence
um there's a quote in your book which i
absolutely loved and it's really relevant
to obviously what we're talking about um you
said that governments are unable to resist the
temptation to create free money for themselves
so explain then the problem with this i know
you've touched on it but i do want to really make
clear the problem with creating that free money
and then also what that means for this a standard
level of skepticism that we should potentially
have when it comes to government because if
they can't resist creating money for themselves
then ultimately are you saying that
they can't help but be self-serving
yes governments of course are self-serving and
why can't they resist think about the olden days
now where gold is the only money gold and silver
how do you get gold and silver you have to mine it
from the earth and once it's above ground um it's
hard to get because there's not that much of it
and then societies are forming and gold and
silver are used across the world for uh commerce
and then all of a sudden a king decides
to take the gold coins suck out the
the metal in the middle and put in steel instead
and wrap it in gold and silver is that fair
full stop i mean really that's
really all we have to ask is it fair
that the king put steel in the middle of
the gold coin and pretends that it's gold
is it fair or not and no it's not fair why because
it gives the king an advantage over everyone else
that's what we're talking about here that's
what bitcoin does it allows no one to fill
the coin with fake coin it prevents that forever
and everyone can verify that with their own
software all you need is a laptop or a phone and
so nothing that a king can do can affect bitcoin
that's the juxtaposition here now i take my
research to the next level and try to explain
as well all the things that are wrong with the
internals of the dollar system and the mechanisms
and honestly the inequity why is it unfair that
they do this what is what is it about qe that
rings unfair for people and makes them frustrated
with central banks and the ability for governments
to create free money for themselves why does that
frustrate them because they watch them do it yeah
you just watch the balance sheet increase and
you can watch the treasuries be purchased by
the fed and you can follow the you can follow the
money literally that they create and what do they
end up buying they end up buying government
debt which the government borrows to and it's
not even that the politicians are stealing the
money and putting it into their checking account
but they borrow for their own political goodwill
and then they never have to repay that
money because the fed either purchased it
or they just rolled the treasuries over for
the next generation and it it kind of like no
one notices right they get away with it they
get away with it but the frustration builds
the anti-politicians stances build and it's all
because of the inequity that people feel when
they see qe it and and i don't want to pin it
all on qe because it's not just the fed's fault
congress when they borrow and spend and then they
argue both sides about the debt limit the left is
in power the right says no debt limit the rights
in power the left says no debt limit increase
everyone is at fault when it comes when it comes
to the fiscal side and then the fed is at fault
for writing a blank check to the government and
the fed is at fault for bailing out the banks
and not letting them see retribution for their
bad fractional reserve creation right it's the
banks that did the bad fractional reserve that get
bailed out because if they were full reserve they
wouldn't need a bailout they'd be reserved right
all of that is is in play and all of that leads
to an emotion that drives bitcoin demand and um
you know for some reason today leia you're asking
me questions that are bringing up the political
side and the frustration very political from the
from the from from the populist side it's not
something that i write a whole lot about but it
is it's it's there it's front and center it's what
was part of my journey as to like understanding
the fed and going down the monetary rabbit hole it
was 2010 qe2 i didn't know about bit i had never
even heard about bitcoin until 2014 and didn't
even read about until 2016. but in 2010 i was like
what the hell is this qe [__] that like i mean
it's this is this is not fair i was 22 years you
know 22 years old like a college student like what
is what do you mean you just what do you mean you
just create and then you buy that's monetizing
the debt and try to explain to me that it's not
monetizing the debt and what is monetizing the
debt it means the central bank just creates money
to fund the government so the fed says we're
not monetizing debt we buy it from the banks
but you issue the government issued it
two weeks ago so they were lying to me and
and that and that set me up and really set me
off down the path of never wanting to let the fed
get away with whatever they said they were gonna
do because i would know the math and you wouldn't
be able to lie to me because i would be able to
observe the mathematics of your balance sheet
and the effects that it has on the market and
markets generally and um you know it ended up
playing into you know my bitcoin research career
because here we are you know as bitcoin advocates
and fed watchers all at the same time so it worked
out well the monetization of debt um that you're
talking about this is something which has always
really confused me so um and also since i'm not
american it's something which has always sort of
been a bit of a question mark but i guess doesn't
even have to be an american thing i guess it's
a global thing but the relationship between the
central bank and the government has always been
really bizarre to me um because people always
think that the fed is owned by the state and it's
absolutely not um it's a private enterprise so
why are they in bed together the the
federal reserve is a bank of banks
yes but they also have been issued their
charter to furnish the currency in the case
of the federal reserve they've been legislated by
congress and approved by the executive branch so
two branches of government instituted this charter
for this bank of banks to basically furnish
the currency of the country so yes it's a charter
but it was legislated into existence and why
because um if we look back at history the united
states tried two different central banks in its
early history both had 20-year charters both
expired um then the united states went went
without a central bank for you know a century and
then they tried it again in 1913 and that one that
version of it has has lasted um and if it was the
people's will to remove that charter they would
vote politicians that ran on enhanced central
bank platform and so i i i don't want to minimize
the importance of understanding how
the fed was created and what it is
but i you know it is the people's will via the
legislative and executive branch to have this
central bank so i'm not out out here advocating
for end the fed or keep the fed we have the fed
and it is nowhere on either party or the
populace's radar to move ahead i mean maybe
some part of the right side has end the fed
as part of their platform but it really hasn't
even close to entered uh something that's on
the national stage as as to what we would do
without the fed or how we would transition to a
world without the federal reserve i think that's
it's really out of um you know any immediate
necessity for analysis it's not in the will of
the people to do it but that that is
the case it's a it's a bank of banks
it was issued a charter in 1913 the
charter has never truly come into question
and so it also makes the currency of the
united states the united states dollar
managed by the banks because it's their currency
it's not actually the fed will tell you that
the dollar policy is the treasuries
but the quantity and price of the dollar is
up to the fed so it's really the fed's dollar
it's not the united states government's
dollar it's not the treasury's dollar
and so that's the relationship as i would
describe it today it's not the clear it's not the
easiest to describe but there there
are distinctions that we should make
you know pretty clear yeah one of the things um
as well which i thought was really fascinating
was um this idea that the va the devaluation of
money leads to government's eventual destruction
and you gave the roman empire as an example
um so how does the cheapening of money lead to
that destruction um and what does that mean for
the dollar right now yes so uh devaluation of
currency can lead to inflation in a direct way
that's what happens when you coin clip or you
you mix silver with copper or you mix gold with
copper and the coins actually lose you call it the
same thing but you devalue it in that you remove
value from the coin but keep the name and that
that drives inflation because people want the same
amount of gold for their wheat and so they charge
more coins so the price goes up because the amount
of gold in the coin goes down that's the direct
relationship between devaluation and inflation
that direct relationship doesn't happen with qe
the fed creates money digitally buys treasuries
from banks the banks keep that money in reserve
they don't necessarily lend it out in the system
it doesn't necessarily drive lending and then
higher demand and then higher prices right you
see the first second third order of effects there
as it works with qe it's actually why the fed
did qe2 and qe3 because qe1 didn't even work to
get it going and so um it's kindle fire but it's
not direct it's not a first order effect and so
part of what i um you know tried to do in the book
was demonstrate that if people wanted to go back
and understand why inflation can lead to societal
collapse you can go look at the roman empire
and and explore that now i'm not a i'm not an
expert on the collapse of the roman empire so
i have to you know put i just have to put that
out there as there there was a correlation that
i believed was true when i was
doing my research during the time
that there was a correlation between the collapse
of the roman denarius coin and other roman coins
during the time due to devaluation and 98
devaluation essentially over the course of a
couple hundred years and it and it did correlate
with the you know the fall of the roman empire
and so that is something that we have to take
seriously from history fast forward till today
and then we see zimbabwe and the
the hyperinflation there and we also
can use the deutsche mark in the in the 30s and
resulting in the third reich nazism and uh and
hitler and so we have some more modern examples
of devaluation leading to hyperinflation but back
to your question is hyperinflation there today and
is it a clear and present danger from the fed's qe
we haven't had hyperinflation in a dollar-based
way we've had an inflation shock in 2021 and 2022
granted it's far from hyperinflation no matter
what metric you want to use you know my cost of
living is not 200 percent higher than where it was
last year um so that is the case but we also see
the fed attempting quantitative tightening for
the second time in six years they're trying to
shrink this money supply they're trying to destroy
money not print money the simple act of the fed
raising rates and destroying money through qt is
evidence that they have read their history books
i mean giving the fed the slightest bit of credit
that maybe they don't deserve because of their
patterns but i will acknowledge that
qt is an effort to destroy money
you mentioned um yeah i mean we have to we
have to acknowledge that money printing and
money destruction are opposites of each other and
even them trying to do it and starting it today
is their attempt to protect the dollar and so
the more that they do it the more that they get
credit from the market of doing that and so is
the bitcoin price going from 70 000 to 25 000
over a year you know the last year's time is that
partially due to the fed extending its credibility
pre-announcing qt and signaling for rate
hikes potentially yes it is potentially yes
you mentioned um at the beginning of the
show that um just because of the way the
traditional system is run it it could it will
expire at some point hence your interest in
bitcoin um however given you're sort of
saying that you know the fed is doing qt
and they are sort of trying
to protect the dollar um
how long do you think the dollar has left if you
do actually think that it has an expiration date
um at least at least 20 to 50 years it's it's it's
it's so embedded in the way that everything works
in this world that there's no way the dollar is
going anywhere and you don't think that could
be like a catalyst event or anything like that but
what's the alternative is it gold no is it bitcoin
absolutely not bitcoin is 500 billion dollars in
size the us dollar spectrum is anywhere between
100 and 400 trillion dollars depending on how
you want to denominate things or value thing
or strike you know stock indices or all that so
we're talking about bitcoin representing less than
or about 1 tenth of one percent
of the size of the dollar today
so what is the alternative is it the
chinese renminbi no is it the euro god no
so we have to we i mean it's just what is the
alternative there is no alternative what's the
alternative to the u.s military what's
the alternative to the u.s geopolitical
position what's the alternative to the
u.s consumer as a source of global demand
we have to factor all these things in when
we think about the longevity of the dollar
and we also have to factor in demographics and
so the way that the demographics are spelled
out today it doesn't maybe in 50 years we'll
have some sort of african and southeast asian
denominated world because of
demographics but it cannot happen
uh from a secular cyclical point of view
anytime in the next two decades in my opinion
so so with that in mind um you know trying
to understand whether bitcoin is or isn't an
alternative um what do you see the use case
of bitcoin then because a lot of bit people
say bitcoin is going to be the world's reserve
currency so from what i understood you're sort
of saying it's a definite no until potentially i
don't know 50 years from now something like that
so bitcoin can be a world reserve asset and it
can be a global online currency and it can rise
dramatically and even exponentially while
the dollar still is the world's denomination
or the world reserve currency so the rise
can happen of bitcoin again because of youth
demographics and going towards one to two
billion people using bitcoin over the next decade
if and when that happens bitcoin has an
online native currency becomes the standard
in smaller denominations maybe not for a you
know american company buying a british company
um they might do it in dollars but you know um
mom and pop transactions around the world might be
you know completely bitcoin denominated in
10 years um and i will point viewers back to
you know a sub stack post that i wrote for the
bitcoin layer a couple months ago or last month
called bitcoin versus quote unquote the dollar
because it's not really the best comparison
we should think about bitcoin versus equities as
something to own bitcoin versus real estate as
something to own bitcoin versus your your money
market fund has something to own but is bitcoin
a denomination today for like the nasdaq to be
priced in no will it be that in 10 years no right
all those companies will still be jurisdiction
usa right issued in the within the dollar spectrum
they might have prices in bitcoin and those prices
in bitcoin might even be the lead driver like
algorithms with algorithmic trading you might
have bitcoin priced apple shares leading the
dollar priced apple shares because algorithms link
the markets but that doesn't mean that the price
on the nasdaq will be in bitcoin it it will
still be in dollars so this journey that
we're on or the next 10 to 20 years of bitcoin
becoming part of our financial society and part
of our uh you know dna digitally and you know and
emotionally to like the word bitcoin popping up in
tv and movies and pop culture and all that kind
of stuff it's that's also part of it right the
word dollar has been part of pop culture
forever now the word bitcoin is in there
so the transition will be gradual it will not
be black and white bitcoin and the dollar will
coexist and they won't even be thought out of as
necessarily competitors in the way that they're
judged suppose as competitors today i think
that it's it's a basic comparison but when
you really dive deeper into that comparison we
can see that it's not really the best what's
the best way to compare bitcoin to gold and to
u.s treasuries using the layered money framework
and comparing bitcoin to you know
london flats for russian oligarchs
those type of mental exercises you know need to
be thought of when we're trying to compare what
is bitcoin what does it represent going forward
um speaking of like the idea of layered money
um this is what i thought was really interesting
because obviously correct me if i'm wrong but the
first layer of money is the store of value so gold
um and then everything as you go down the lace
become medium of exchanges whether it's like bank
notes or promises or you know promises to repay
um so the interesting thing about bitcoin is where
does that stand in the hierarchy of money because
it's the store of value it can be the
medium of exchange and then is that for
you what makes it unique to all other types of
assets out there the layers of money refer to
the hierarchy between a few things number one
the hierarchy of instruments and the hierarchy
of instruments depends on the hierarchy of
balance sheets and whose balance sheets are they
the financial institutions so the layers are
really about who owns what in the financial system
where does it come from so your checking
account comes from a commercial bank
the commercial bank has other
assets as its layer above your money
but gold is a commodity that comes from
the earth it's not issued by any financial
institution therefore it cannot exist as
a second layer of anything gold is just is
and not only is gold is but gold is purchased
as the asset to issue money against by financial
institutions historically speaking right they they
the banks own gold and they market as an asset and
then they issue gold certificates as money and in
that way gold is the first layer of money so what
is bitcoin bitcoin is the first layer of money
because it's not issued by anybody all you have to
do is have a miner a you know a piece of hardware
and you can generate the coin on your own and then
any exchange like bitmex can have bitcoin on their
balance sheet as an asset and then issue bitcoin
balances to their customers as a second layer form
of bitcoin and it's all about the balance sheet
bitmex asset bitcoin bitmex liability
bitcoin deposit and in that way bitcoin is
has very little historical precedent the
only thing you can compare it to is gold
and how insane is that that you've actually
invented something that you have to go back
basically all of modern history to try to find a
precedent and you can only find one precious metal
which is you know god given or earth given
and so it it really and that by itself
bent a lot of people's brains including my own
that you've actually created a first layer money
that nobody issues and it's a system that can keep
itself without an issuer therefore no counterparty
risk no default risk and that can serve as
the collateral for an entire financial system
in the way that we saw a financial system develop
between the 13th and the 20th century based off of
gold again that's what layered money the first six
chapters are about how we built a financial system
based off of this pristine collateral called
gold we have a new one called bitcoin which uh
sets the stage for you know miraculous advance
in monetary science but we're in the you know
absolute first stages of it because people don't
even recognize that it's the collateral that we've
been waiting for they still think it's like paypal
or you know some other second or third layer
medium of exchange when it's really a first
layer of money and happens to do all those
other medium of exchange functions so um it makes
bitcoin you know once in a generation innovation
that's uh that's good to know that's what i was
gathering when i was reading through so i was like
okay right i'm getting this this is making sense
um but what's interesting as well is the term um
fix the money fix the world um so i think it would
be important at this point to just make clear
how important money is so do you feel
that money is the center of everything
uh yes you know i do and i do
think that if you fix the money
you can fix a lot of the problems in the world
and that is why i am here i don't advocate
for any political position because i think this
is so much more important the money that's why
i focused on the fed i focused my career
on fed study truly because i believed that
the the money system was broken and i wanted
to understand it and i believed that if you
fixed the money it would do more
than voting one way or the other
and i made that decision as a person in my
early 20s and i've never looked back you
know back that's like you stopped voting uh
you know i'll say that um i i don't have any
i don't have any political energy to give my
energy is in this it's in the monetary field
uh that's that's the best way i can answer your
question i don't have i don't believe that the
political energy is where i should dedicate any
of my effort passion or intellectual capacity
to advocate for or against political positions
i want to focus on the monetary system
and what is money and what it means i believe
it's broken and uh you know dedicated my career to
research and the education on the monetary front
you know exclusively so you know my viewers and
readers will hold me accountable that you know
i won't dabble in politics it's not why i'm here
that's so interesting because i um i always feel
although bitcoin is a political um it it just does
have and i can't help but feel it these underlying
kind of libertarian ideologies in terms of
you know decentralization so there isn't one
authority which can dictate what has to happen um
but i i know a lot of people don't sort of
agree on that no i do agree with you i do
agree with you and um you know i can admit that
the political bias that gets that people have
that makes them attracted to bitcoin can have that
slant and it's it's my slant as well that i just
i believe in that i believe in that freedom
that's part of you know what i would but
i express it now through bitcoin and i think
that the bitcoin is the political platform
because i can believe in bitcoin i don't have
to pin my hopes on a politician or a political
party or even a even a piece of legislation um or
the law in english language i love math and so uh
bitcoin is is a mathematical political
platform and that's something that you know
can excite i think um anybody i understand
um just finally what do you think about um
the future of decentralization so
you know we had kings and queens
and then power sort of devolved to governments um
we saw further devolution um right now personally
and we don't really need to get into this
but i sort of feel like things are becoming
more authoritarian there's more centralization um
and so it feels like sort of going the other way
um but do you think we're gonna get onto this
whether it's a bitcoin standard or a decentralized
standard whereby you know we see a lot more um
yeah decentralization of power basically i think
that you'll have the coexistence again of you know
the dollar bitcoin you'll have the coexistence of
the more totalitarian side and the more
completely decentralized digital first
um you know um passport-free sort of you know
mentality so watching that develop over and and
and really watching bitcoin's influence on that uh
going forward it's going to be very interesting so
i agree with you we're seeing uh you know
a move toward totalitarianism in many ways
at the same time a move toward decentralization
in any in many ways so um i think that the fact
that we still have the growth of bitcoin despite
everything else going on around the world is a
positive sign that bitcoin will continue to see
its own light right that we will continue to see
a future in which bitcoin is a part of people's
lives that will influence families family offices
countries companies and to go that direction it'll
influence politics as well um i don't have any
strong prediction of how that will develop
outside of the united states i'm hopeful to see
you know from my perspective random i i don't mean
that in any disrespectful way but random countries
coming on to a bitcoin standard like el salvador
and central african republic they're random in
that they don't have a position in the global
economy but it's not random that people or leaders
from small countries want to explore a new
monetary reality so yeah they will randomly appear
on our scene but in those countries it will feel
the na you know like a natural um evolution so i
as long as we see that and then you know from the
united states perspective i completely believe we
will see um states go full bitcoin you know i look
to tech you know texas and what they're doing and
um so we'll have jurisdictional arbitrage all over
the world totally agree with you um jurisdictional
arbitrage is is a great way to put it um i think
we're already starting to see that anyway um in
terms of um in terms of the pandemic and medicine
mandates and all sorts of things some are more
authoritarian and totalitarian than others um yeah
so that's pretty interesting just cross the border
oh yeah just go up north a little bit that's right
yeah exactly um but nick it's been such a pleasure
i want to thank you so much for coming on how can
people get in touch with you follow your work how
can they buy your book laid money absolutely so i
appreciate you having me today leia i had a lot of
fun uh great questions and great interview
everyone can find all my links at layeredmoney.com
so that's layeredmoney.com links to the book
on amazon audible people love the audiobook
you also have a link right at the top to my sub
stack uh publication called the bitcoin layer
uh or you can find that directly
at the bitcoinlayer.substance.com
perfect thank you so much nick it's been such a
pleasure and thank you everyone for watching if
you enjoyed this video please don't forget
to hit the like button and also subscribe
so you never miss a video and you help support
the channel because we have very important
conversations here um and we uh try to wake
people up and bring them to the better side
um there you go so nick thank you so much
thank you and also major thank you to the
sponsors bitmex step finance and block fight we
will see you all next week malaya high open show
you